الى العراق هناك جدل اثره اعلان للاتحاد
العراقي لكمال الاجسام رفض اشراك النساء
في اللعبه سواء داخل البلاد او المشاركه
في المسابقات الخارجيه بالفعل هذا الاعلان
الخرجه بحجه ان اللعبه تخالف العادات
وتقاليد واعراض المجتمع المحافظ فائز عبد
الحسن رئيس الاتحاد قال انه يفضل ان تمارس
النساء هذه اللعبه بغرض الحفاظ على
الرشاقه لا بغرض المشاركه في البطوله
والاتحاد يرى ان اللعبه مخصصه للرجال ح
صرا مثل لاعبات الى
فقط وباشراف كادر نسوي
ليش على فائز عبد الحسن يعني الرجل قال
هذا الموقف ويجب ان تقف ولا تشارك المراه
العراقيه او حتى تلعب هذه الرياضه مو الكم
نحن كنساء
او ناشطات او لاعبات
مختصه مهتمات بالجانب الرياضي
احنا ضد هذا القرار
قرار تمييزه طبعا قرار تمييزي رياضه
مبدئيا يصح عامه للجسم تعتبر علاج طبيعي
قوه عضليه تحسين الصحه العامه
محافظه على الجسم من الامراض المزمنه ممكن
امراض القلب وغيرها والسكري
تحسين مزاج عموما زينه هو يعني التصريح
كان لا يتحدث عن انه النساء لا يجب ان
يلعبن الرياضه لا وكان بيتحدث عن نقطه
معينه
العبوا رياضه قد ما بدكم ولكن يتحدث عن
نقطه معينه وهي المشاركه في مسابقات دوليه
اللي ممكن
بعتقد انه اللبس عاده بيكون منافي للعادات
والتقاليد المحافظه العربيه
فهذه هي النقطه شو كيف تعلقين على هذا
الموضوع المشاركه في بطولات دوليه تحديدا
الموضوع لا مشكله به
[موسيقى]
الشعب او المجتمع الشرقي تحديدا
بعده طوائف وكل طائفه تلزمها عاده وتقاليد
من الممكن انه يفرض الاتحاد الدولي يفرض
على اللاعب انه المشاركه واللاعبه طيب زين
يعني
اليوم مرعب ممكن تشيل البيت تشيل اسره بس
رايحه النادي شايلات لي 200 كيلو
لا يعني يعني شلون ماكو مشكله قاعد يقول
لك انه والله لا تدخلين بطولات هذا
البطولات رجالي حكمون فيها وانت شايله هذا
الثقل او بناء حتى بناء الاجسام فبالتالي
استعراض هذا الجسم وعضلاته
يقول مو مقبوله
لا منطق لعادات لا تقاليد واحنا نطالب مو
احنا نطالب بالمساواه بين المراه والرجل
كيف نميزه والعنصر الرياضه هاي تحديدا حدث
هاي للنساء للرجال ما ما تصير
[موسيقى]